[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon
distinguished colleagues
graduates
friends and family greetings to you
joining us online from all around the
world
i'm lynne cooley dean of the graduate
school of arts and sciences and i am
delighted and grateful to have you with
us as we gather to celebrate
achievements of the classes of 2020 and
2021 of yale graduate school
[Applause]
to begin
i want to acknowledge the indigenous
peoples and nations including mohegan
mashintuck at pequot eastern piqua
scouticock
golden hill pagasa niantic the
quinnipiac and other
algonquin speaking peoples who have
stewarded through generations the lands
and waterways of what is now the state
of connecticut
we honor and respect the enduring
relationship that exists between these
peoples
and nations and this land
welcome to our alumni degree ceremony
for the yale graduate school of arts and
sciences and i'm going to go a little
out of order and say a very heartfelt
thank you to our superb uh organist mr
film philip balkin who is one of our
many accomplished yale college students
playing on one of the world's great pipe
organs in woolsey health thank you
[Applause]
thank you to our graduates for pausing
in your post-yale lives and returning in
person to our beautiful campus
we cannot replace or restore everything
the pandemic has taken from us
but today we have a chance to rebuild at
least a part of what we lost
at last we can celebrate your hard work
and success
celebrate the beginning of your
professional lives and the many ways in
which you now serve the world
ceremony is important it is how the
academy recognizes the dedication and
commitment you and your families have
made for your education
and the expanded expansion of human
knowledge writ large
it is a means by which you can fully
embody this the transition from graduate
student to your professional identities
it is also a day for congratulations
we acknowledge your contributions to our
community and to your respective
disciplines
we hold you in a collective embrace
before we send you off with our best
hopes and wishes
you will continue to learn to discover
to investigate to share knowledge
it may be fair to say that your journey
to knowledge has just barely begun
yet we recognize and mark your passage
from student to teacher from learner to
learned
it is a profound reorientation of your
place in the world and deserves to be
acknowledged
over your time at yale you may have
heard me say that our mission as a
school is to train scholars and push the
boundaries of knowledge
that this requires being comfortable
with uncertainty and that the skills you
accr acquire while doing this will make
you capable of tackling difficult
questions with rigor and discipline
while it's certainly true that the
pandemic profoundly affected the final
stage of your time at yale you have
adopted and persevered to finish the
degrees you came to yale to accomplish
you may have had to cope with your own
illness the illness of family members
even the loss of loved ones
we've all had to learn to do everything
differently to cope with travel
disruptions and to live with uncertainty
despite these historic difficulties you
persisted with courage to complete your
studies
you found like others who have gone
before that graduate school is very much
about negotiating the frontier of the
unknown
even now as the pandemic is not entirely
loosed its grip on us
we cannot yet assess it with the clarity
of hindsight
but i hope and believe it has provided
us with experience to make us better
problem solvers to make us more
compassionate
more thoughtful
you never know what you will be asked to
do
but the ability to identify a problem
and pursue it to a solution is a
powerful tool
your skill in solving complex problems
working with others embracing
differences
and building constructive relationships
will serve you well when faced with the
vicissitudes of work and life
challenge our challenges are certain
your abilities are proven
you are ready for all of it
uh please allow me just to take a moment
here to name several groups of yale
employees
beyond our established and devoted
faculty who stand at the heart of yale
and when i finished we can thank them
all together
the university's custodial and
maintenance staff who make yale look
beautiful and keep us in good condition
all year long the hospitality staff who
feed us at commencement and throughout
the year
the clerical and technical staff who
conduct the university's business with
acumen and dispatch
the managerial and professional staff
who direct and administered our
departments and schools
and specifically the staff of the
graduate school of arts and sciences who
sustain the institution within which
yale graduate education thrives
now for all these wonderful women and
men of yale i ask for your recognition
through applause from
[Applause]
and now on this day of joy and
togetherness we are proud to present you
with a memento of your time at yale
please come forward when dean allegra
debona ventura reads your name
to congratulate the degree recipients
we will also be joined at the front of
the stage by faculty members from from
departments and programs
and yes
you may applaud whenever you see fit
in former times
such applause for individual graduates
might have been thought a little bit
impolite but we welcome it so go for it
dean debona ventura
thank you dean cooley
for the degrees in african american
studies
for the doctor of philosophy
shanna john baptiste
[Music]
[Applause]
brittany nicole
levingston
[Applause]
for the degrees in american studies
the doctor of philosophy
courtney lindsay akiko sato
[Applause]
damien vergara
bracamontes
[Applause]
alexia
victoria williams
[Applause]
for the degrees in anthropology
the doctor of philosophy
today
neely airton
[Applause]
elisa paradise
[Applause]
jacob
rink
[Applause]
kyle
wiley
[Applause]
for the degrees in applied physics
the doctor of philosophy
lin shu lee
[Applause]
for the master of science
nasser bader ahuti
[Applause]
teemo kevin kristen
[Applause]
nikita ermolav
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i can take that one
[Applause]
roping lee
[Applause]
for the degrees in archaeological
studies
for the master of arts degree
adrian elise natalie
[Applause]
[Applause]
for the degrees in cell biology
the doctor of philosophy
joseph
ryan
amick
[Applause]
anna elizabeth eastman
[Applause]
kevin james hughes
[Applause]
david faller
[Applause]
when
sorry
when ping sao
[Applause]
for the degrees in chemistry
the doctor of philosophy
gurab
banerjee
[Applause]
ipsita
gauche
[Applause]
anthony christopher screws
[Applause]
for the degrees in computational biology
and bioinformatics
the doctor of philosophy
don hoon lee
[Applause]
kevin lee lopez
[Applause]
for the degrees in computer science
the doctor of philosophy
luciano dybala
[Applause]
jeremy kernig
[Applause]
marco mitrovic
[Applause]
rey
zhang
[Applause]
for the master of science degree
diming chew
[Applause]
wei
zhang
[Applause]
wong
[Applause]
for the degrees in earth and planetary
sciences
the doctor of philosophy
neela marie creasy
[Applause]
jane
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
yoshinori miyazaki
[Applause]
sarah marie arvison
[Applause]
for the degrees in ecology and
evolutionary
biology the doctor of philosophy
larry lee bowman jr
[Applause]
jessica rose glass
[Applause]
for the degrees in economics
the doctor of philosophy
ian schofield ball
[Applause]
eduardo pinero fraga
[Applause]
oren sorry
[Applause]
samitra shukala
[Applause]
nicholas snatch hall woodhams
[Music]
connor walsh
[Applause]
[Applause]
you joe
wong
[Applause]
for the degrees in engineering and
applied science
the program in biomedical engineering
the degree of doctor of philosophy
rebecca marie lacroix
[Applause]
yo me posey love
[Applause]
micah sam brickman reardon
for the master of science degree
bow
[Applause]
for the program in chemical and
environmental engineering
the doctor of philosophy
randolph a calendar
[Applause]
akshay deshmukh
[Applause]
for the master of science degree shuron
way
[Applause]
the program in electrical engineering
the doctor of philosophy
mayor bay
salehi
[Applause]
for the program in mechanical
engineering materials science the doctor
of philosophy
shubo jyoti chaudhry
[Applause]
rodrigo miguel
oyeda mota
[Applause]
chi kai wu
[Applause]
zhang
[Applause]
xiao zhou
[Applause]
[Applause]
for degrees in environment
the doctor
of philosophy
wong
[Applause]
lauren nicole pincus
for the degrees in european and russian
studies
the master of arts
madeleine
ellis
muzdakis
[Applause]
for the degrees in experimental
pathology
the doctor of philosophy
uting you
[Applause]
for the degrees in genetics
the doctor of philosophy
daniel burkhart
[Applause]
julianne alody gordus
[Applause]
diane molly manray
[Applause]
michael
sarant
[Applause]
jn song
[Applause]
[Applause]
for the
for the degrees in history
the doctor of philosophy
kevin michael feeney
[Applause]
mirai
juliet pardon
[Applause]
justin
randolph
[Applause]
for the master of arts
keith
casey kokoza o'hara
[Applause]
harry
llewellyn perkins
[Applause]
for degrees in the history of art
the doctor
of philosophy
laura rose
phillips
[Applause]
for degrees in history of science and
medicine
the doctor of philosophy
jesus park
[Applause]
she
[Applause]
for the degrees in in immunobiology
the doctor
of philosophy
ping min chen
[Applause]
for degrees in the interdepartmental
neuroscience program
the doctor of philosophy
usman farooq
[Applause]
gao
[Applause]
gia lisa g
[Applause]
the end do you
nuang
[Applause]
for the degrees in international and
development economics
the master of art
yasmin katerina fire
[Applause]
sanju
[Applause]
grace epen
[Applause]
yija gao
[Applause]
valentina gets
[Applause]
pablo
antonio guardia
coutinho
[Applause]
rhea gupta
[Applause]
praksha jane
[Applause]
mark khalil
[Applause]
dalton matson
[Applause]
walla
[Applause]
nishka sharma
[Applause]
[Music]
she
[Applause]
asta porja
[Applause]
john
[Applause]
srinivasan nithya
[Applause]
for the degrees in italian studies
the doctor of philosophy
julia claire pucci
[Applause]
for the degrees in linguistics
the doctor
of philosophy
ricker duckham
[Applause]
martin fox
[Applause]
for the degrees in management
the doctor
of philosophy
marjam kim
[Applause]
for the degrees in mathematics
the doctor of philosophy
guangyu job
[Applause]
for the degrees in medieval studies
the doctor of philosophy
sebastian ryder bezera
[Applause]
gina marie
hurley
[Applause]
for the degrees in microbiology
the doctor of philosophy
kelsey hall
[Applause]
emily elaine putnam
[Applause]
emily
elizabeth shine
[Applause]
for the degrees in molecular biophysics
and biochemistry
the doctor of philosophy
kenneth ivan brewer
[Applause]
kirsten
connect
[Applause]
for the degrees in molecular cellular
and developmental biology
the doctor of philosophy
kuhn bondarshuran
[Applause]
for the degrees in music
the doctor of philosophy
stephanie acevedo
[Applause]
laura jean brown
[Applause]
brianne dolce
[Applause]
liam patrick heinz
tawa
[Applause]
brian andrew
miller
[Applause]
william watson
[Applause]
for the master of arts
harry peter castle
for the degrees in nursing
the doctor of philosophy
bridget bazil ibrahim
so
abby muller
[Applause]
for the degrees in pharmacology
the doctor of philosophy
eric
michael rosenberg
[Applause]
for the degrees in philosophy
the doctor of philosophy
ryer hello
[Applause]
for the degrees in physics
the doctor of philosophy
supraja
balasu
[Applause]
charles brown iii
[Applause]
christopher
davis
[Applause]
air pete dua
[Applause]
raymond ellers
iii
[Applause]
tyler harrison lutz
[Applause]
no
[Applause]
christian favor
[Applause]
for the degrees in political science
the doctor of philosophy
maximilian clements
bernhardt krahay
[Applause]
[Applause]
gotham
niar
[Applause]
matthew
shaffer
[Applause]
alicia steinmetz
[Applause]
for the degrees in psychology
the doctor
of philosophy
elizabeth janet lewis
[Applause]
for the degrees in public health
the doctor
of philosophy
yi shen
chang
[Applause]
mo
lee
[Applause]
renee
mera
[Applause]
xiaochan wong
[Applause]
the master of science
wen han liu
[Applause]
ju yi tang
[Applause]
wei tian
[Applause]
you mean why
[Applause]
you schwann wong
[Applause]
ning john
[Applause]
for the degrees in religious study
the doctor of philosophy
joseph
loftus cummings
[Applause]
pratima gopala krishnan
[Applause]
lucia ruth
halsether
[Applause]
justin joel
white
[Applause]
for the degrees in slavic languages and
literatures
the doctor
of philosophy
jacob evan lassen
[Applause]
for the degrees in sociology
the doctor
of philosophy
mustafa yavas
[Applause]
for the degrees in statistics and data
science
the doctor
of philosophy
elena kushanova
[Applause]
tao sarika
[Applause]
[Applause]
shin shu
okay graduates
uh hang on like to make sure we haven't
okay
i'm going to now ask
as i call out each degree to have the
recipients of those degrees stand and
remain standing
after which we can all congratulate you
collectively on your marvelous
achievements
master of arts
master of science
doctor of philosophy
[Applause]
okay please stay standing for just a
moment
it's our tradition in the graduate
school to recognize that the time the
commitment of time effort and attention
required for you to achieve your
advanced degree was only possible with
the participation and support of not
only your professors and classmates but
also your families and friends
i invite you to turn to those in the
room with you today
and acknowledge the help they've given
you to reach your degrees
okay you can sit down now
you have been an integral part of one of
civil civilization's highest inventions
the research university where the
mission is the creation of new knowledge
as you have learned finding new
knowledge new truth about our world is
not a solid a solitary endeavor
you have lived within an academic
network in which you can follow your
curiosity
rigorously test your ideas benefit from
critique
and go forward in an unexpected
direction
you have learned that convinced that a
convincing argument backed by evidence
from primary sources or well-controlled
experiments will stand up to critiques
and importantly pave the way for the
next person to take another step
savor this and rejoice in this it's a
rare privilege to have had the
experience and to apply what you've
learned throughout your life
finally please take a moment to reflect
on the people who helped you
helped to help you make it through
graduate school and to find your career
path
as you benefited from being mentored
consider being a mentor yourself
think about sharing your knowledge and
experience with upcoming students
through the graduate school alumni
association or by signing up to be part
of cross campus our portal for bringing
alumni and current graduate students
together for networking and career
support
you may not realize how much your
experiences can already be of benefit to
others
graduates
friends
families together with the faculty and
staff who are with us
you are all invited to a reception
immediately following this ceremony in
the calkins courtyard at the mcdougall
center where we started out this morning
please join us for this celebratory
occasion
please remain in your seats until the
platform party recesses from the
auditorium
then process yourselves
out to the reception under the guidance
of our ushers
on behalf of all of us at yale
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you